verdon subutex alors là on part sur les
traces de votre héros qui chaque fois
qu'on se plonge dans votre style faut le
dire on en prend plein la tête alors on
se dit est ce qu'on va réussir à aller
jusqu'au bout oui je vous le dis parce
qu'on est embarqué à la fois par vos
héros par les histoires par aussi votre
fulgurances parce que vous décrivez une
société avec vos mots avec votre point
de vue aussi on va y revenir mais c'est
un parcours en marge de la société que
vous nous décrivez un sdf qui va
d'aventurés en aventures dans tous les
sens du terme personnel sexuelle sociale
aussi ce que vous décrivez en fait c'est
un monde chaotique fait de cynique et
d'indifférence si je résume
ouais les gens qui ont de la peine à des
gens connus chagrin je pense que ça
parce qu'il est ce qui les relie tous
après leur chagrin prendre des formes
différentes à chaque fois mais ce qui
les relie tous et qu'ils ont ce quel que
soit leur âge quelle que soit leur
boulot quel que soit le quartier dans
lequel ils habitent ils ont de la peine
quoi il ya tant que cerveau méchant
alors il faut il faut resituer aussi
peut-être dans le contexte parce que
vernon subutex votre héros c'est un
rocker alors quand on pense trop
compense années soixante dix on a
l'impression que c'est un peu vieux mais
pour vous rockeur c'est un système de
valeurs ça veut dire des valeurs
lesquels là c'est des gens qui ont été
dans leur cadre à le faire lorsqu'il
concerne les légendes qui va avoir dans
un premier temps sont des gens compter
dans le rock dans les années 80-90 à un
moment donné où ça a voulu dire quelque
chose ça voulait dire pas avoir
exactement la même vie que nos parents
pas avoir la vie rangée dont pouvaient
rêver nos parents tour nommé pour de
bonnes raisons pour à la recherche de la
vérité du plaisir de
une sincérité cherche perdre on suppute
avec ceux ci dont il continue à le
chercher il continue à le chercher un
peu changé le rock mais ni contrôle
continue à chercher ce père évidemment
parce que c'est compliqué parce que
parce que c'est compliqué parce qu'en ce
qui le concerne il a tout perdu petit à
petit sans qu'ils s'en rendent bien
compte qu'une étant ça s'est délité
autour de lui et la question d'éviter
tous ceux qui sont autour de lui c'est
quoi alors ya des gens qui sont ravagé
par la drogue
d'autres qui sont qui sombre dans le
cynisme de la violence aussi il ya un de
ses copains qui est qui est très violent
mais je voudrais insister là dessus il
ya quand même des moments humains où il
ya des petits moments où il ya de la de
l'humanité de la chair et les gens se
touchent se regarde
il ya beaucoup de gens dans ce time goes
by a pas mal de gens dans ce livre qui
se rend compte qu'on rien à voir
ensemble et qui réussissent carla a
communiqué à se connecter abandonner dès
fois effectivement ça peut être vraiment
sûr un truc que idiot ou sur un truc
simplement de désir mais il ya quand
même des connexions de sid est là et il
ya un tome 2 est normalement dans le top
10 et se connecte encore un peu marre
aussi de là où ils réussissent mais je
voudrais juste parce que votre style
accompagne cette description de la
société alors on connaît votre style
rude on peut le on peut le dire comme ça
pour faire simple de trois extraits
paris ne se portait en son sein que les
enfants de propriétaire le reste de la
population allait poursuivre son
parcours ailleurs la poste qui fait la
poste l'entreprise qui fait partie de la
démolition méthodique de tout ce qui
fonctionnait à cause de bouffonnerie
tard est sorti de l'école de commerce
par exemple où elle est géniale la dette
leur invention passe comme des [ __ ]
s'en tape ils passeront leur vie a trimé
pour essayer de rembourser au passage
vous régler des comptes mais se fait
parler les gens donc parfois c'est pas
directement ce que je pense ou alors je
le pense mais moi j'ai des garde-fous
aider
j'ai un contrôle de morale plus fort que
certaines des personnages quoi mais
effectivement je règle des comptes
pal dans suis pas la seule à trouver
dans paris c'est dur quoi c'est idiot de
dire comme ça mais que moi que c'est pas
une ville qui a invité en ce moment à la
bonne humeur et à la relaxation et
effectivement c'est très dur vernon
subutex tout ça c'est dedans c'est un
roman à rappelons le dur à bientôt à
numéro 2 j'espère vite ouais j'y suis en
train de terminer vers d'accord et ce
sera plus positif plus optimistes c'est
ça qui est difficile oui bah oui mais
moi même temps je trouve pas si
pessimiste non une premier donc
peut-être que je me trompe sera alors
aux yeux c'était en tout cas
[Musique]